alright sorry we've been out for a bit
I've been out of town I was out of town
for a wedding oh I just had some matric
tattoo work done so if I seem a little
out of it
yeah teacher I swear it's the reason our
homeworks net did oh but uh yeah have
you seen my facebook I said that uh but
yeah we're back talking about gravity
falls Ross Canada Steven universe is
going again and the real thoughts and
everything so we're just we're gonna
watch things like bastards today it's
gonna be like the laziest yet most
productive tape from be logs um so okay
so we're talking about this episode of
gravity falls we're dipper once again is
trying to get over Wendy but thank God
they go into a home add too much I
didn't want to get this out of the way
to begin with if you were to tell me
that this episode would end with a giant
corn cob smashing Stan's headlight in
and saying that's what you get so we
ended walking oh let's get yeah it was
bizarrely like the most funny line I
would have believed you cuz out of
context that was so bizarre even for
this show I was like wow oh that's just
the weirdest things how we ended up
there from where we started is just what
I love about this uh um cat that it's
like I had the lighting perfect than the
sun's like I'm gonna go wee for a bid no
matter what I'm always in the shadow for
some reason every time we do this like
look at this I am so much friggin day
you know what me nuts get some light on
me finally goddamn it yes that helps a
touch now you went oh like an oompa
loompa yeah kind of I don't care you can
see me at least um so okay so it's an
episode where they go on a road trip to
prank all the other sort of mystery
shacks out there this is something
they've he claims they do to each other
but I think he just does to them uh and
dipper is getting it violin oh I stand
when he said you got to watch out for
this old lady she seems nice but she set
my car on fire two non-consecutive time
she was pretty good throwing that giant
needle pin um but uh yeah reminded me of
a mom from Futurama oh but it runs the
robot company has this image of all
sweet nice but secretly is atotal our
mom for
seconds oh wow I don't forgive that what
the hell she do to you
not again like just shit out this needle
oh god the stalker it's okay um so then
he tried to learn how to be canvas
pickup artist all these girls on the
trip uh and but then candy gets
attracted to him and they turns out that
all his pickup tricks work against him
because it stands advise and it turns
out that the woman Stan is interested in
is a giant spider lady it happened um
which by the way even for this show was
fucking nightmare fuel
i I'm like I'm a grown-ass adults the
face off and the spider comes out I was
like oh shit oh shit oh shit no and I
don't even have a rack enough Oh me and
my wife would flip the fuck she would
not be able to watch you can't even say
the word spider around her ya know she I
she would literally like be hiding under
the bed until I told her spiders with
her and then she'd flee from there sis
but yeah so but I'm a grown-ass adult
that was like fucking Sheila and more to
the Rings therefore you know it's fine
because they were uh it was both kind of
creepy but also really funny when I
don't know it was all money on it and
what I liked it was also legitimately
disturbing and for this show the
darkness of now I know where they get
the mummies from like wow that's fucking
dark you see all those gala time event
that is pretty messed up cuz it's like
there's just all these dead eaten people
in the background and foreground they're
all over the place it's like yeah you're
right I mean they don't advertise it too
much but it's like yeah that's pretty
twisted yeah the body-count this episode
is actually really high you just don't
see it happen in front of you um it's
gotta be at least 20 because I sound
like a dozen mummies there were
skeletons in the background I'd say this
episode of these twenty people are dead
but you know she's funny uh she was
really funny actually um I you know I
like the fact that the designs of her
cuz at first you know you're seeing sort
of these different designs of spider
people in the pamphlets and stuff and
then when she comes out and it's just
her lower Hansel spider in the air
a bit half it's human and first of all
discipline I know that's still pretty
funny just here come out of you know hey
honey oh you so funny and everything but
she has just the spider body oh she's
talking with the spider legs talking to
them and doing the quotes with aspire
late but then the way she reveals her
real self was really funny and creative
but also the design I don't know it
wasn't just a spider it seemed like they
added a few more things or put the I
serve in different areas and the little
one of those are tusks or whatever uh
yeah and made her really funny and
really creepy at the same time uh you
know but still a choice by making her
funnier and by having the animation so
stylized I think a beta we fucking creep
ya know by light even though as she
moves the way she runs away is really
funny and really fast but yeah it's
really creepy too when she got squashed
for a second I was like holy fuck I
thought they liked Gilbert either he's
gonna be like dude blood like flying and
I was like okay like she's still alive I
guess what I was like wow this episode
was messed up hmm um and yeah at the
very end
dipper a different candy do not get
together which I'm kind of happy for I I
still really ship him in Pacifica just
like they have real chemistry it's the
first shippers down with a girl and I'm
just like you know I tried it this seems
to work that wound up showing so he says
is in the beginning like he's like I
come back to win again he's like man I
really wanted Pacifica and then there
was like this pause and like he was like
sitting behind me it's like Holly shit
I'm turning into a fanboy and then there
was another voice like it's more like a
fangirl I'm sure and yes you are I'm
sure fanboys ship too but it's it's
mostly bad girls and we all know you're
very obsessed with the romances on this
show yeah well I mean it's one of if
they're good I'm totally down for it-- i
have no problem with romance in anything
it's all i know i am a different kind of
fangirl I'm just obsessed with Mabel
doing stupid thing it's so it's so fly
cuz I'm a big Bob's burger marathon run
through and it's so funny to go back and
forth between like cuz I first myself oz
burgers I saw like oh right yeah it's
just Mabel and that's it but it's like
whoa no joke Oh Mabel she's yeah
like Otakon Bob's burger that there is a
difference and same thing with John
Benjamin I like to think it's about
Benjamin but it's like they are
different it's a bizarro universe
version of Mabel like her like the
long-lost like the evil twin of Mabel oh
right because it's like it's the same
voice in the same sort of goofy attitude
but it's so fucking dark I'm Bob just
because every time I see gravity falls I
always think of myself oh I'm just gonna
watch Mabel and I'm just gonna see her
as Louise light you know I'm always
afraid it's gonna happen but you know
they're different care they do have
different energy and they do have this
different charisma um so I think that's
wonderful because they're both really
the same boys I mean there's very little
difference but they as you said it's the
same with HM Benjamin you you sit there
and think oh it's just that voice yeah
but what he was talking about it the
difference between Bob's Burgers and
Archer and coach and coach McGuirk off
of home movies and he's like there is a
difference he said he didn't even
realize it till he did the Bob's burger
crossover episode and Archer and he
realized that he was affecting at
different voices like they do it and
when I watch it they I mean they're
obviously the same voice but they do
have different tones and approaches yeah
but way more laid-back Archer is always
shouty and overconfident like there is a
difference and coach just doesn't give a
shit about anything and it's the same
ways yeah like wheeze I think is more
shrill my kind of psycho kind of like
there's like just an evil kind of twin
stur voice when Kristen Schaal does that
yeah maybe a little bit more of a caring
about what she yeah into um you know she
will be like Mabel squeeze uh Mabel
basically Mabel squeeze and Louise
laughs maniacally yeah the difference
see like the difference between
squeaking and shrinking pretty - um and
uh yeah well and then this kind of ties
into what we've always kind of said
before about like because I think the
whole thing is like a lot of people see
is like pickup artists and stuff like
that which isn't entirely incorrect it's
like oh they're like the predators and
stuff like that and they're the
manipulators and stuff like that women
can be just as manipulative I mean both
you know have their own sort of set of
traits that they can use on the others
and both have advantages and
disadvantages but I think kind of the
idea
that honestly I think for most men just
being a woman is the manipulation yes
that is always the thing women try so
hard to look good and pretty and stuff
like that is that you clearly don't
understand guys you got us already
you just got office I mean it'd be
wearing a burlap sack and we'd still Jim
Abbott is so fucking high yeah but um
but yeah but I'm not that I would
recommend doing that but no but there is
this idea that I be we both whatever the
Balbo sex is it's fun to joke about and
have fun with and stuff like that but
then the people take like really
seriously no matter all evil no women
are all evil it's like weird that people
kick people can be nice people can be
dicks it's just were just people you
know we're different but it's just we're
all gonna find our own way in our own
advantage is to play to our strengths
yes so crazily philosophical well no but
that's part of the fun I mean it's like
I don't know I always like talking about
my children no but I like that stuff I
like talking about sir like the
differences in gender and stuff like
that and having fun with it you know
again the the strengths and
disadvantages and stuff who uses it for
good who uses it for bad and the fun
differences I think it was just more
about Stan being a terrible Roma well I
like that units at the end Hey look yeah
I've been divorced once I've been
slapped more times I can count and stuff
like that um and there I love in the
middle all the girls being at that
turrets tramp because that first you
know yeah you're kind of like with the
log on her head ya know what what like
exhibit or tourist trap that was nodoz
remember is like long holiday releases
the beaver okay got it reminds me of the
Wisconsin Dells yeah everything there
reminds me Wisconsin tell that upside
down place I lived in the Pacific
Northwest and I don't remember being as
bad as they're portraying it here like
but you go like the Wisconsin Dells or
something and that is just so much shit
yeah like the Mystery Spot the house on
the rock it's like if you literally want
to see gravity falls come to life God
when it comes to the tourist trap thing
go like booked a vacation the Wisconsin
Dells booked a vacation for the water
parks and then make sure you've got a
free day to do all the use
shit exit Oh stupid tourist tracks at
all the supernatural stuff that like is
in gravity falls and wisconsin dells
claims that they don't it's just the
people just the people there are the
scary things that you see and go oh my
god that's gotta be like big birthday no
it's just like you know the crazy old
lady there's no I I think we out of
themselves as being familiar that's all
annoyed odds is like we make fun of like
Indiana and Wisconsin test but to be
fair that's all they do with us too but
at least we're not Ohio yes yes fuckin
Ohio um but that's all they do know
their God may pull you over for farting
while driving I swear
um but uh yeah well what's the lie was
it uh if feeds is what they always call
like it's someone's driving like an
asshole the calling feeds fucking and
walking out on masses it's come faster
that's a fail Cannella bastards yeah
that's because people from Wisconsin
don't know how to drive best time yeah
but of course right now uh noise what
we're driving on an illinois express
when you're doing like 45 miles per hour
at the fuck yeah everyone's guys is like
you know where do you have to get in
such a hurry to do stuff we have things
to do I know you and Wisconsin just want
to go and look at your tourist traps at
your upside-down houses go wow this got
really anti Wisconsin I'm sorry
now we're gonna every secure boy from
Wisconsin now Johnson does initiative
Packers Envy and yeah so much a thing no
I lower the other Packers a lot of like
that there is no Sakura I always someone
like the Packers are awful but the beard
fuck what do you think about that it was
like I think you just told me something
I already knew like it's like well what
would you like to be it's like oh yeah
I'm like there is nothing you can do to
us like somebody's like well what do I
say when somebody's like oh well the
Bears suck I'm just like well if they're
Packer said this is it's like there is
nothing you can do to us that we have
not done to our site there is a you
literally cannot hurt us we are like
that bastard who's gotten his ass beat
and is bleeding on the ground and gets
back up it's a come on come on no no
we're that psycho bastard like green
bait they've never suffered they don't
know what true suffering is fucking
great
yeah the Packers know what something
whenever the Packers like don't make it
to a Super Bowl there's always this
litany of YouTube videos of Packers fans
crying yeah now I gotta watch the
Patriots
well more sympathetic to that I couldn't
be but like it's like oh my god it's
just like meanwhile we just go out with
like a season where maybe we've won
three games like oh fucking hell
like that's it we don't sit there crying
like it's just where we were happy we
have our three seats and we're heavy
when we're happy we got three wins
yeah go ahead zero like the Lions did
that one year so yeah now we're talking
about football we are way up but but
yeah they don't know suffering they know
that the Packers know suffering being a
peg we're like like you know only
Packers fans are happy for the Packers
but it's like the Patriots it's like
yeah you may win some games but nobody
likes you just a little more I think
more people like the Packers nationally
though the pain no no that that the
Patriots
completely fucked themselves over
big-time well that's right I mean that
hey Joe does not know and likability
that's even the Patriots don't like the
Patriots now at least the Packers like
the Packers nobody likes the Patriots I
did well that's like the Patriots of the
rock bottom of likability and yeah
that's pretty no now it's like you've
just made it impossible to like even
your own studio our way was that their
own stadium booing him at the Super Bowl
or whatever when they won or like when
the coach went out there was like the
fucking boo oh I don't know
I forget what you're talking about but
no I'm able when they want super yeah
when the coach whatup era was just like
oh yeah well you know I don't remember
cuz most Super Bowls from you're just a
drunken orgy but yeah oh I'm sorry
that's win um but yeah we really got on
subject I'm sorry
Oh point being we know what it's like to
suck do you know what suffering is like
they're they're like that's like silver
spoon shit going on I'm there I'm just
looking and be that we're supposed to
get off this gravity fall it was good
episode oh sorry we got said had nothing
to do a football yeah oh you know it's
good for you're gonna delete all this
cuz we're gonna have the entire New
England area and like Wisconsin just
stop watch
I don't even know if they watch that's
begin with maybe they did this is just
odd they're gonna use it or did cuz
clearly they're not anymore they're
gonna sit there like they always do and
just be like well we'll just take all of
our Superbowl champions and fear and we
kind of have nothing to say it's like
yeah fuck it's all compromise it but
that but that but you play like this
drunken assholes now yeah but yeah that
is kind of compromise we're going on
that's what though I'll tell you how to
bring it back to gravity falls we are
football team like we are the grunkle
Stan football team we suck we know it
we're in denial about it Bart is like
yeah well onii-chan and we go prank the
oceans around this kind of thing with
like both Chicago and New York and we
act like we hate each other so much and
stuff but it's like with both of them
there's so much compromise there's so
much like yeah well you got this shit in
this Genda shit like yeah we have this
shit - it's like yeah well mmm
why was when the best thing you can say
about your area is your sports team you
got nothing it's really what it comes
down to umm but yeah anyway this good
episode
I blame I blame you yeah it's all about
making fun of different states in the
States making fun of us it's um can we
pick up North Dakota now yes thank you
it's all building up to hawlucha
North Dakota is easy okay yeah that's
way too easy
Oh bout Dakota they got those faces on
the mountain we are going to anger
everybody in the United States by the
time this view log is over he'll have
nothing to a gravity falls but at least
we will pissed off everybody Mississippi
Alabama Florida West Virginia - easy I
don't think yeah yeah I mean he'll we
can make fun of the rest of United
States just by saying - easy easy
there you go Washington's stay bunch of
pretentious coffee drinkers we live
there we know yeah we definitely um you
you think you think like there's a
liberal media and stuff like it all
comes from Washington it's like it's
like this is this is where they come to
home Rhode Island oh I'm sorry you mean
the other colony of Massachusetts yes
hold on Oh got some under but natural
there's Rhode Island's like the neutral
zone between Connecticut and
Massachusetts the gumbo
teaches ya and mansions on the beaches
so you just feel weird no it's like they
have rocks on water that's their Beach
Maine Stephen King that's all well yeah
that's argument there uh no actually
remodel we really got apologize I will
not apologize for Vermont's cheese
Bernie Sanders should that's it oh my
god
okay hmm see what y'all about wind sorry
yeah I'm sorry uh it all started with
Wisconsin yeah there's anything Colorado
fucking Broncos hey they gave us Jay
Cutler fuck okay we are stop because
we're like this is too addictive like
just when we get into insulting state no
we should keep going because at least we
should show that we hate all states
equally
oh I do every state has something stupid
um missing Illinois Illinois really
Illinois is too easy
we literally come from a place called
Crook County honestly what pisses me off
is when I read like about scandals that
happened in other states I'm like come
on I thought we were a number but this
is like Thursday for us Wednesday it's
like when we get to them really bats our
governor tried to sell a Senate seat and
shake down a children's Oh
number one ah okay any go we asked off
we I get we have so much stuff to watch
so yeah sorry Jana no I'm sorry to
America we're out here Mike but but
Montana no no Montana
I've got nothing to say about Montana
can you think of something no it sure is
kind of nice it's they got that glacier
net it's your guy or em on the mountains
a little too fucking close to Canada
Canada they go like no damn it 51st
state auto shop